so once they're off you know one of the
biggest phrases that we're hearing and
it's not just a phrase it's the real
thing people have to do is adhere to the
idea that silence is not an option and
so it can't be a coincidence
obviously that your podcast is is titled
that way when you think about the people
that are listening what are you hoping
that they are able to glean from the
conversations you're gonna be having
what's just what you said I hope that
they are listening Carlos I hope that
they are letting their guards down and
first of all listening you know that old
adage where you see you know you can't
be a good friend or you can't learn
anything if you're talking umm so I
think people in this moment to let their
guards down listen will actually admit
first if they have a problem then let
their guards down and listen so that's I
I just want people to absorb it and then
I want them to go back to their friends
or colleagues or co-workers their family
their whoever if they want to talk to
their dogs or whatever and then have a
conversation with people and I hope they
learn from the podcast and they take
some of the actions that we actually you
know give them the instructions that we
actually give them - especially the
first podcast if they take those actions
and do something in their in their own
lives mm-hmm one of the guests I spoke
to recently had a very insightful thing
I thought that she said which was you
know everybody is gonna do this at their
own speed everyone's gonna get this at
their own pace but I need you to get it
and even in the first podcast you're
very open with the idea that you know
I'm not perfect I'm gonna get a bunch of
things wrong as well I don't know are
you ever concerned with the idea of
being vulnerable in that way on your
podcast or on your show about getting
things wrong yeah yeah listen I as a
journalist I don't want to get things
wrong I mean it's sometimes maybe I'll
take the wrong approach or I'll say the
wrong thing or someone may not be ready
for what I'm going to say or where the
conversation is going to go but I think
perfection is boring trying to be
perfect perfect is boring and so I think
that there is people crave authenticity
and when you're authentic there's
vulnerability owner ability is
automatically part of the mix when you
are authentic and so my authentic self
is to be honest and to be candid and to
tell you exactly where I'm coming from
and how I feel I'm not an ambush person
I don't like to ambush people with
things that they don't expect but if you
if we're in a discussion I expect you to
be honest in that discussion as long as
our intentions are good I don't think
that we should castigate people
especially in this moment I've said that
everyone needs to cut each other some
slack because there's so much tension
there's so much Boehner bill
vulnerability already mixed in with Koba
19 and people not knowing where they're
some people don't know where the next
meals are gonna come from they don't
even know if they're gonna go to work
look we're not even in studios now we're
at home people don't know how if their
kids are gonna be in school next season
or or now so I think we all need to cut
each other some slack and I think that
the podcast is a great place for that
that's what I want what and that's how I
want people to react and interact when
they discuss and listen to this podcast
yeah you reach on your show is so
massive on we watched you on CNN it's
funny we were talking about the idea of
listening right because oftentimes we'll
see your show and there are a lot of
people talking but nobody listening
right and over each other right yeah so
you know what was it about the podcast
space that serves your idea of listening
and having conversation better than you
can on television okay so if you want
the really honest thing was is that I've
been trying to write this book about the
exact issues that we're going through
right I've been trying to write it for
years and it's just been with my
schedule has been tough people have said
at least some in the publishing industry
that these books don't sell you know
they're great and you know we love it
but they just don't sell and then this
all came about and now you know
everything is a number one about race
and how we talk about it what language
we use in the vocabulary and all that
it's all number one now and so I wanted
to write this book years ago but then
when this happened I wanted
to be out now I'm what it's like stay up
overnight and write a book and I
couldn't do that because it's just not
possible so I was going to approach CNN
about doing a podcast and I opened my
email and there is the head of digital
saying hey done you ever think about
doing a podcast so it was just sort of
serendipity everything came together and
I'm glad that I had now this outlet and
this platform to be able to to have
those conversations and to say what I
wanted to say in a book yeah your guests
already in the first two podcasts have
been interesting and there's amazing so
much to say who who is your ideal is
there is there such a thing as an ideal
guest for this podcast like is there a
name that you want to be on there having
conversations like the difficult
conversations with you besides Carlos
Bustamante I don't know no I mean listen
I didn't expect to have my mother on
write and so we were talking about about
movies and about Gone with the Wind and
about you know it was it was pulled from
HBO Max and they wanted to put it into
context and someone said well what do
you know about movies and I say I know I
said I know a lot about movies I talked
to my mom every day and we watched
movies together long distance and so I
think the perfect guest is the perfect
guest for that moment I don't have to I
don't want to say you know I want to get
the you know the former president or
this diplomat or that person I want to
who's ever right for the moment and that
doesn't necessarily mean a big-name or a
famous face I do think in this time
right now the young activists who
started the black lives matter movement
who are continuing on in that vein who
are carrying on the mantle were carrying
the torch I'm picking up the mantle I'm
carrying the torch I think those are
great voices to have on the podcast but
the best guests are everyday people
because that's who I'm talking to
mm-hmm my name you know we
to elevate the voices that haven't been
heard and a big part of this whole
conversation about like whose voices
should we be hearing right now one of
the big jumping-off points of it was was
when you called out a bunch of
celebrities on that and then there was
that conversation I went a goo-gooing
Dave Chappelle said well they want to
hear from me because the streets talking
um where do you sit now with the idea of
celebrity and I know that there's lots
of layers to this lots of nuance this
but what do you sit now with the idea of
celebrity is speaking up and speaking
out well I think I agree with Dave
Chappelle you know I gave my how I felt
I said how I felt about Dave Chappelle
on CNN I agree with him I think that the
streets are talking and I think we
should allow the streets to talk and we
should allow those activists to to do
what they're doing do it do what they're
doing and they should be out front and
and at the forefront of this I just
think that it this is all hands on deck
and if you have any sort of platform or
any sort of outlet then you should let
those young people know that you support
them you should also let the rest of
America know who if your celebrity or
constituents or your fans or whomever
know how you feel about this particular
issue because celebrities have influence
they influence people that's what
they're called right influencers right
that's what the whole this whole new
thing that you have on on social media
now I'm a social media influence if you
have any sort of influence to influence
a culture then you should reflect the
culture and you should also let your the
people you're influencing know how you
feel because then that will help society
change if you just sit there to go say
anything then people may continue on and
do do it the way that they have been
doing it but we need to do it
differently now and so I'm not saying
that celebrity should speak out or
celebrities are bad if they aren't or
they're good if they're if they are I'm
not saying that at all I'm just saying
this is not a moment for modesty
everyone get out
hold throw your hands up however you can
and say I support the change for
equality that's happening in America are
you noticing being
mr. bean are you noticing tangible
change in your workplace 150 percent I'm
noticing tangible change in not only in
my workplace but in my friends and
people I don't know people who are
receptive and also in people who don't
want change the people who don't want
change are fighting tooth and nail even
harder so that change for that change
not to occur and most of the people I
know most of the thinking people most of
the people with a heart most of the
people who realize that equality is for
everyone
they are receptive and open to change
how could you not be everyone is sitting
at home everyone is vulnerable because
of what's happening and then you see
people literally dying on your
television screen see we saw two black
men within the MS fan of two weeks dying
on our television screen Ahmad Audrey
and George Floyd and when you're sitting
at home vulnerable and you're worried
about your own kids and you're your own
well-being and your own safety and you
see this it can't you can't help but be
open your heart is open and so I don't
think we'll ever get this opportunity in
my lifetime where people are so
receptive and open to change and
understanding how their fellow man may
not have the same equality as they do
mm-hmm
you know we just talked about people
that are fighting against change and
there are people at all levels of
profession life and even in your
personal life that for what all the
talking in the world all the news clips
and they're all all the statistics in
the world you can't get through to them
about what needs to happen in your mind
how do you how do you influence a person
who's not ready for it
how do you influence a person who maybe
thinks that they've already got the
answers and they're fine where they are
those are the toughest to reach that's a
very good question I think you have to
do it by example but I'm I also think
there's only so much that you can do and
I think people who are so averse to
change are in some ways like an addict
they're addicted to their bigotry
they're addicted to their misogyny
they're addicted to their racism
and until they realize that there's a
problem there may not be any there may
be no reaching them so I think sometimes
you just have to let people go until the
world leaves them behind and either they
are swallowed up in what's left behind
for them or they realize that they they
must propel themselves forward in the
future and so sometimes I think you just
some people quite honestly Carlos I
think our lost causes and so you have to
leave those people behind and then still
lead them lead by example and lead with
love but I think that now the majority
of people around the world are
especially in northern america i should
say are are open and receptive and they
want to change and they want at least
what America says is justice for all
right and a more perfect union yeah you
know we see you at the forefront of so
many changes in history right we get to
you present a lot of this to us when
we're looking back you know
grandchildren great grandchildren
looking back at this time the way that
we would look back at the sixties and
the seventies and the things that
happened then what side of history do
you want to be on how do you want those
people to receive you I think yeah yeah
how do you want them what do you want
the books to say about this well I want
the books to say that this was like a
civil rights movement right like the
march on Washington like the you know
the March is because there was more than
one march across the Edmund Pettus
Bridge on the same day you know that
people document I want them to say that
this was a pivotal time where America
made a leap forward towards equality and
justice for all people especially
african-americans who had had not
received that American dream and that
promise of a more perfect union for
everyone and I want for myself selfishly
to be on the right side of history I
don't want to look back at some old
footage on television and see me saying
this the wrong thing
because and you know and then I'm
putting that in relation to looking back
at the George Wallace footage because at
the end of his life you know he
denounced what he had stood for in the
beginning of his life right segregation
now segregation forever and what Easton
you know but he said so I don't want to
be that kind of person obviously I'm not
that extreme but I just I want to be on
the right side of history and I want to
be one of the people helping to pull
people into the present which was
happening when they you know when that
footage happened but also into the
future when they are watching that
footage when they're looking back in the
rearview mirror because I think the
young people who are out there are
saying to us in so many ways I
appreciate what you did you you got us
this far
you took the train this far but now it's
time for us to become a conductor and
some of the things you did were great
but you didn't move far enough and fast
enough and you weren't strong enough so
here we are we're here and we're gonna
do it so we got this take care and so um
that's what that's how I want history to
read to reflect what Who I am and what
I've done